hey Mark what's going on what are you
doing just thinking about what a great
week has been here at Bloomberg politics
we sure cooked up a lot of great stuff
there was that time Kanye tried to steal
our show that time we took Hillary to
Brooklyn year was like a Tresh sarah
Beeny on earth there you go that time we
asked Alabama Supreme Court Chief
Justice Roy Moore about who he hangs out
with I've had many friends who were
homosexual that time we wrote a letter
to Lincoln a birthday we enjoy
celebrating most occurred 10 score and
six years ago today that time we found a
new job for Jon Stewart things change
but what really matters doesn't that
time we found the directors commentary
for the Vox interview with obama sup
Millennials Liam and Jeff hear that time
I almost killed John in the kitchen hold
still you big baby that time we covered
the Ukrainian Parliament that time we
jumped the shark with the fondest
memories of tarqah shark
that time we stumpf the senator what's
the best place if you're trying to win
votes teeth Lebanese food in New
Hampshire what's that place called oh I
knew you're gonna ask me that i can't
remember that time justice ginsburg went
gangsta and i didn't know about
notorious b.i.g and then i discovered we
had at least one thing in common we both
grew up in Brooklyn that time we made
David Axelrod eat a sandwich not getting
any food on his shirt was a little
mustard on his hand but technically not
on his clothes we'll get you next time
David